[Music]
a new uh star wars video game is coming
out
and of course we've been star wars video
games before this one is getting some
attention because it's going to allow
players to have same sex relationships
in the star wars video game so you can
take whatever character you are and have
a same-sex relationship within the game
that's right it's a first for a star
wars video game and as you can imagine
it's causing uh quite a controversy
judge for yourself we actually got a
hold of uh
but we did we would
why is that hard to buy
this is a pretty important show yeah
george lucas decided that only one show
could have some clips and it would be us
right and that's just the truth right
and that's just because wheel of fortune
said they did andy no one has to know
about wheel of fortune here's some of
the star wars game that allows same-sex
relationships
you were great out there today very
powerful thanks i'm loving this rain i
know right reminds me of the night we
met do you want some tea i feel like
something sweet you're my something
sweet
i love you love you
where do you want to go to dinner moss
eisley cantina i feel like we always go
there
our place it is what about jabba's
palace selfish bastard you are
i heard they're legalizing marriage on
cloud city
you can't avoid this subject forever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]